[Music]  Brad Pitt opening up about that big  tell-all interview his first since  splitting from Angelina Jolie in case  you missed it the 53 year old actor  addressed sobering-up with GQ Style  magazine admitting to stoner days and  boozing too much in the past now Brad  tells The Associated Press quote I've  got no secrets I've got nothing to hide  adding if we're not talking about it  then we're not getting better you know  we came out stronger on the other end  despite his divorce drama Pitt seems to  be in good spirits and says he's focused  on figuring out the new configuration of  his family with Jolie the father of six  adds quote kids are everything they're  taking all the focus as they should  anyway whatever's got to be done to keep  the family together